[Music]
remember TJ Miller
kind of remember when TJ Miller got
totally got fired from Silicon Valley
but he pretended like it was his idea to
leave
oh yes remember when TJ Miller almost
got a [ __ ] Federal time in jail
because he called the fake bomb threat
on a train because he was mad at a woman
I do also remember this well his career
is looking up I talked to Michael Bay
yesterday never heard of him and I
haven't either and he called and I was
like Michael what I didn't even say who
I go Michael what call me when you're
what do you mean what the bay what are
you talking about water what are you
saying here dick I'm sorry
like a straight Andy Dick you're right
that's exactly what he is a straight
Andy Dick a lake and uh Michael Pond
he's yeah I would never call that man
Michael Pond
um but we were just talking about the
being a Maverick because I think he is
he's a genre inventor that guy like
created a genre Legend he's so he's
Legend Michael basil Legend
[ __ ] Legend
yeah just ask my Megan Fox
well you can't because of the NDA
no you can't ask her unfortunately
totally she just can't answer you think
Megan Fox if you think you think before
she hung out with she hung out with
Michael Bay she was wearing vials of
MGK's blood around her neck no I don't
think so
I don't think so somebody broke her and
it was probably Transformers too
legendary and he's talking about
Mavericks and also forget Michael Bay
imagine it being having to be in five
movies with Shia LaBeouf
that [ __ ] poor girl I actually feel
bad for Megan Fox they broke her
and that's you guys are both Mavericks
ew ew
stop it explain to me what Brian Callan
and Brendan [ __ ] shop are doing that
is Maverick like
I I'd like to know flying fighter jets
I think he's just looking at them
through rose-colored lenses
[ __ ] off get him the [ __ ] out of here
get his head on the door on the way out
I'm gonna throw you out like Jazzy Jeff
you [ __ ] got to Uncle fill you
out the door I do not
that's it that's it I'm bringing our
bouncers up bouncers up that's it we're
done
that's it Eddie Kingston's up talk again
see what happens on site on [ __ ] site
okay
good
and that's just a word that I've been
thinking about and talking about
and you know talk about the media just
being like what would be a clickbait and
it'll destroy the true story they were
like oh TJ was crazy people were like oh
yeah I did I wanted to move on because I
was like people saying TJ was crazy
notice he didn't go but I'm not they
were wrong
don't like doing things for more than
five years he doesn't like doing things
for more than five years like you know
his sobriety
it's about his max yeah I don't like
doing anything for more than five years
I don't tell people that when they hire
me which [ __ ] them down the road but
hey what do you want from it and also
they're the first actual big Film
Production Company they gave me a shot
because before that I was the guy
holding the camera in Cloverfield
that's really true and I got to the
point and this is how much I really care
about the audience there he goes
uh can I ask you a question mark just
I'm back up a little bit because you're
I saw a little bit of this and I was
I'm not as good at you as this so I want
you to look at his tummy do you think
he's coked up
I just you didn't hear me earlier I said
he's getting that drip oh I'm sorry I
swear to God I swear to God when you
said the drip I know I'll tell you what
I thought you meant oh you thought you
meant as close yes I swear to God I was
like I mean I guess it's true I'm a bad
bro I I honestly thought you meant
clothes because when he at one point he
did this weird like
like it's a weird throat swallow that
really I've only done in my life when
I've done Coke
you got to get your tongue in there to
try to get it off the floor yeah you're
trying to scrape that drip out
okay real quick what are you talking
about why is why is Brian Cannon look
like he's running numbers for Sammy the
bull why is he dressed like that because
he probably is no not yet they're
buddies now
um
why does uh why is Brandon Schaub dress
like the first openly trans Soldier and
on the right TJ Miller's cocaine the
genre Legend he's so he's totally
legendary and he's talking about
Maverick and that's you guys are both
Mavericks and that's just a word that
I've been thinking about and talking
about because you saw Top Gun and you
know talk about the media just being
like what would be click bait and
destroy the true story they were like oh
TJ was crazy people were like oh yeah I
did you call the bomb threat on a train
that's not the media [ __ ] with you
bud why don't you move on because I was
like I don't like doing things for more
than five years that's really true and I
got to the point and this is how much I
really care about the audience right
here cooked up cooked up completely um
geeked out I started being on autopilot
I really noticed that I was showing up
too comfortable and I was I was just uh
sleepwalking through it and then people
will say like did you smoke weed on set
and stuff and no they give you fake weed
you know but I really thought I got to a
point where I was like I could be
totally stoned this entire time I mean I
play a stoner you were stoned the entire
time yes they give you fake weed but
most of the actors don't actually smoke
fake weed they smoke real weed stop yeah
come on [ __ ] stop with that [ __ ] yeah
they don't they don't let you smoke weed
on the show so they give you Salvia
they give you spice oh God
who's always high and I had gotten into
the Rhythm it was five years because the
pilot was imagine your career being guy
getting being on an HBO show and your
job is just to be high all the time why
are you complaining TJ what's the issue
here bud so it's Four Seasons five years
and I could have just gotten high and
kind of that could be my job and we're
great I never get tired so it's like I
can get high that could be my job yeah I
want you to click into a character after
that it's just you get you get bored
look at bored and also you're doing it
as service to the yeah the same reason
that you uh left the Goldbergs
oh he was on there too yeah Brian Callan
left the Goldbergs oh bro that's what
I'm saying like TJ Miller no no but that
but that's Brian Count's giving the
advice from you oh yeah you left because
of what happened yeah because of the
unpleasantness yeah the audience but but
also because I like this audience I want
them to think and I don't want them to
be like
oh man that was such a funny show and TJ
was great but then in like episode five
and six they were really trying to like
shoehorn them in there I don't want that
yeah yeah and I I think to the level of
success that show is at for you to walk
around that time I think you must be
like I can't believe he's walking he
didn't walk away he's lying he was fired
there was like several people that work
with him that said he was impossible to
work with nuts
I mean again you see Brendan Schaub is
such a p brain right that he actually
thinks that he he first off he's trying
to give TJ Miller credit like he's Dave
Chappelle Dave Chappelle walked away
from his show that's walking away from
your show right They begged him to stay
and he said no [ __ ] you and he left
that's not what happened with TJ he went
crazy and then called the bomb threat in
swag him oh I'm a fan now so that's what
Hollywood
um
once he was no longer on the show it's
like I'm a fan of that guy because I
like the show but then when you walk
away I'm like oh that's some gangster
it's true HBO and Hollywood was like why
are you what why are you leaving because
the system doesn't work that way yeah
and you finally made this Show's so
successful
as far as speaking with people like he
doesn't have any conversational rhythm
maybe you should have asked me Papa with
that new thing he's doing then
[ __ ] [ __ ]
and I I also had a component of it that
was like I was doing film and I was
doing spoke stand up every night yeah
you were doing stand-up every night how
you would go to the bathroom and do
stand up every night right
this bathroom is terrible to do Coke in
I always think of American Psycho I'm
sure so I do 14 hours you know I mean
you can be on the [ __ ] set I was
doing I shot schools right next to you
guys what you did what you shot School
holy [ __ ]
Brian I know your dad was in the CIA but
Jesus Christ calm down
[Laughter]
afterwards I do 14 hours you know I mean
you can be on the [ __ ] set I shot
schooled right next to you guys on the
Sony lot yeah so you guys literally so
that were you one of the Sandy Hook
actors yes
don't we're gonna lose a billion dollars
I'm kidding I'm only joking I'm joking
it's only joking my my trailer was here
silicon Valley's trailer was right here
you guys were all over here yeah it was
we were right next to each other and I
would do yeah but the thing is you were
on like a [ __ ] Hulu show and he was
on an HBO show right he knows I would be
working a six narrow day I would try I
would schedule so I I'd have an hour and
a half to run to Santa Monica do the
podcast and come back and I do it in my
my [ __ ] outfits I press them and not
miss the pot I pet the Pod bro
y she can't miss the pod
casters are short enough word podcasters
are short enough word it doesn't need to
be the pods even shorter
because you come in makeup
because you know Royce they don't have
time
for full words but the word maverick is
just as easy to say as podcasts I say
MAV
yeah we say MAV now oh really okay
uh-huh
well you're a bunch of gets yeah it's
good it's good absolutely good but I
because I was doing stand up
every single night and they had to move
stuff for me to do I also was like and I
had a psychotic break during that point
it's just remember remember bro I love
this I love this they go they didn't
fire me because I was crazy he just said
that a minute ago and now he's like I
had a psychotic break
so TJ what is it buddy
as we were talking about before and so
they definitely were like you had to say
you had a psychotic break if not you
would have been charged for calling in a
false bomb threat I'm with you that's
what your lawyer told you to say bro
every time you're asked you had a
psychotic break
they gave me an out you know they gave
me this really funny way to leave the
show which is Ehrlich it's just an opium
den and that's where he stays forever so
I thought that was so funny but they
also were kind of like you know this is
hard so maybe do you want to do three
episodes out of ten or seven or what and
I was like no I think this is just such
a perfect time to leave it such a funny
way to leave
and the HBO was so sweet they just were
like oh that's good I'm sure you really
want to do and I go yeah and I think
that Hollywood in general not HBO they
call you in general it's like but don't
you want to buy a boat yeah and that's
the mentality it's like couldn't you
always stop pretending like you being an
idiot with somebody else's fault look I
know Hollywood is evil we've been saying
that forever we've talked about it a
hundred percent
but also I don't like people like they
get kicked out of Hollywood and go I
left because it was evil no no you would
have gladly stayed there longer if they
allowed you to okay it's true yeah true
yeah all right you you would have you
would have gladly gladly stayed there
longer if Sullivan and Sons had another
season not to be specific
always want to be a TV actor a TV star
everybody wants that stand and I was
like no I want to be a stand-up and also
I don't want to buy a boat I want to
live in Manhattan with my wife and do
stand-up comedy what do you hear Brendan
do you hear Brendan you can't help it
that's comedy comic sets sets comedy I
need to be part of this I if I don't
talk people are if I don't talk people
are going to realize I'm a sham if I
don't talk people are gonna figure me
out that's Brendan all the time if I
don't want to talk the facade's gonna
fall they're going to see that I don't
know what I'm doing oh my God I have to
that's all he's stupid just so you know
right when you have a guest on treat it
like me and Royce do oh it's gonna be a
nice easy day yeah let them talk let
them talk it's nice sit back I'm not
neither one of us are so insecure that
we're like oh God if I'm not talking
what are they thinking who cares let's
get Alex Jones on you just sit back and
go all right man I'm just gonna crack my
Knuckles and lay back in my chair that's
it he's got it under control through a
couple live reads show's over yeah
that's it bing bang bong let's go let's
call it a day be it a TV actor a TV star
everybody wants to understand I was like
no I'm gonna stand up I want to be a
standout and also I don't want to buy a
boat I want to live in Manhattan with my
wife and do stand-up comedy and so
that's kind of the impetus behind
leaving yeah yeah important but now I
have this kind of weird situation this
haunting conversation yeah ghost ghost
you do the comedy zones yes yeah yeah I
don't know what that is that's actually
really funny I could picture him going
oh ghost ghost
he's great and he came to me and we were
talking and he you know he's got all
this stuff going on and then I was like
you know I think the problem is that
people don't know that I'm a stand-up
set so I'm trying to get more stand up
online I think it's special yes I think
it's a big part of it either that or I'm
not a great Santa but they kind of they
you know they know me as an actor and
they're coming to see me as an actor and
then afterwards like whoa he can
actually be stand up so I think I need
to show everybody that I have seen TJ
Miller stand up it's not it's not great
the best
yes I mean I'm sure you are a Santa but
let's be honest you're more of an actor
at this point right
you you weren't you weren't a [ __ ]
guy that was doing sets and then broke
into the biz as the kids say